beware of false prophets who come to you  in sheep's clothing or inwardly they are  ravening wolves  Jesus is the shepherd who protects you  from the world  I miss dog sheepdog to get the Lambs  back on track when they stray off the  path some of you have strayed haven't  you Reverend says he have to take you  back where you came from I know you're  there and I know you can hear me you may  have my thumb there is nothing wrong  with your ears  you know why I'm here  I'm here to punish you why she was  indeed the same Iwate  you water it is lusted  ain't never going to stop it I've seen  your mother she's the kind of person who  turns the other cheek be like her  never leave your loved ones alone  you should not it by now  you